okay watch so this is what people are
gonna be talking about today so you guys
are prepared
the first one is absolutely really
mind-blowing because this brings up a
lot of moral and ethical questions so
what Chinese scientists helped create
the world's first genetically edited
babies he is going to jail
his name is Ho Jane Kwai if China he is
going to be put in prison for three
years for carrying out what the Chinese
government says were illegal medical
practices so last November he alarmed
scientists around the globe saying that
he successfully altered the genetic code
of two twin baby girls critics
questioned his ethics and fear that
could open the door to designer babies
and the scientists defended his work to
the Associated Press the world has move
on to the stage for Amber generating
there will be someone somewhere who's
doing this if it's not me in someone
else according to chinese state media to
other scientists through the courts that
had Kent had conspired with him will go
to prison as well so you know this
brings up a lot of questions you don't
want people to be able to design their
own children to genetically modify their
embryos I was wondering what he did and
it says he used chemical scissors to cut
out a gene that would infect the person
with HIV right so what he was doing was
preventing the possibility for these
girls to get HIV so some good that can
come out of it there is but that they
say it can pass future generations and
risk harming other genes I mean I feel
like we're there and we don't know what
this really could bring there's a lot of
unintended consequences
you